Once the adapter is initialized,
let's bind it to the ListView.
But you may notice that we don't have
a reference to the ListView
in our fragment.
It was only defined in the layout XML.
The system takes and inflates
layout XML files,
and turns them into a full view hierarchy
with a root layout of the main activity
at the very top of the view tree.
We can also assign IDs
to each view in the tree,
but it's not required if you don't need
a reference to an individual view.
For example, this ImageView doesn't have
an ID associated with it and that's okay.
Within the Java code
of the associated activity or fragment,
if we need a reference to the button,
we can simply call findViewById,
which will traverse down the view
hierarchy until it finds a view
with an ID button,
and then it will return that.
Similarly, we can traverse down the view
hierarchy to find the linear layout
with the ID container,
and then return that.
We could do the same to find
a reference to this TextView
by traversing down the view hierarchy.
But you'll notice that we already have
a reference to the container
which is the direct parent of this TextView.
Hence, we can just call
container.findViewById
to search this subtree to find
the TextView with this ID,
and then return it.
With this method, we have a smaller
sub-tree to search for a given view,
as opposed to searching
the entire view hierarchy.
In the Android Java doc
for the View class,
which is linked below
if you want to follow along,
it contains an example with a button
with Define in Layout XML.
It was assigned an ID, my_button.
Then, in the Activity, we can use
the findViewByID method with that ID,
so that we can get
a reference to the button.
Then we can change it dynamically,
such as by adding a click listener to it.
Now in the Placeholder Fragment class,
bind the adapter to the ListView.
Luckily, we did assign an ID
to the ListView earlier,
so we can find it easily now.
Think about the smallest sub-tree
in the view hierarchy
that you can call findViewByID on,
then set the adapter on it.
If you want an example,
you can see one in the link below.
Check the boxes when you're done.